wow so classic
this entire fight i would guess took
them a few weeks
that part where she knocks the goon
towards them catches them and throws
them is that two wire gags
hey everybody welcome back to another
episode of stuntmen react i am joined
here by gita silva and aaron tony and
this is gonna be a good time these guys
are giving me some of the best insights
into fight scenes and hard stunts and i
think i got a couple clips that i can
show them that are going to make you
guys go ah and so if we do that it'll be
a successful episode we'll see
we'll see here we go i trust nico nico
always brings out some good stuff i have
a whole list on my phone like i have
good stuff you do yeah i love this dope
anyways let's jump in
born to fight have you seen born to
fight of course yes
yes this car scene
is terrifying
let's watch this
yo god damn
that was clear okay you're right the
moment of like pure like ragdoll as he's
in the air he's spotting it the whole
time too he did a really good job of
this because you can see that he starts
to kind of slow himself down with his
right leg he's like okay i'm gonna tap
good i'm good you know what's funny it's
not even funny
the thing about that is he went in the
dirt but you still see that he caught
whiplash right and that's some thick
sand yeah he looked like he he had fun
yeah i was about to say that actually
my god yo there's no wires there's no
wires there's no safety no nothing oh
you know thailand thailand is wild man
um
how would you actually approach this
shot okay there is no way that when you
hit this first one you are not going to
bounce back there's no safety there's no
way of calling cut this is a one-off
you're going to bounce and you're going
to try to land in the middle as best as
you can but his inertia and the fact
that he's going forward is kicking him
and now that he's rolling he knows as
soon as he hits he's like i'm [ __ ]
right now i'm sorry i'm saying that he
literally feeds as tight as he could
because he knew any other person if you
would have got flash knocked out you
would have been out and you would got
ran over done but he knew he knew what
was going on he was like i'm too close i
need i need to go ahead and turtle and
he did is it worth doing something like
this for a film oh yeah yeah why not you
saw that reaction we just had from it
yeah okay it was worth it you need to
set it up accordingly you know what i
mean right would i do it no no it's one
of those things where you're like this
is the risk this is where a stunt person
is unfortunately expendable but you know
that going into this job you create a
sense of excitement for the crowd
and you sign up to do this when you guys
are like standing at the crosswalk you
ever like look at oncoming traffic if
that car swerved and went to the
sidewalk i would jump over it like this
like you guys ever do that not that but
what i do do i look at windows and i go
i could jump through that at home in new
york you go down to the subway and
you're like i can make that gap
[Music]
okay has anyone seen the zack snyder cut
i haven't played i'm not watching it
yeah i'm waiting for my girlfriend okay
listen it's four hours nico it's gonna
take a minute you need to like set aside
like a day put the kids to bed like
maybe like drink a red bull because
but it is good i thoroughly enjoyed this
and i'm so glad zack snyder was able to
go back and finish this because it's
beautiful who's the double for wonder
woman as a couple joanna bennett and
then alicia vella bailey as well we had
a ton of people in the comments asking
us to do a vfx react to the older
justice league and the newer one and
compare them go check it out
[Music]
it's so interesting seeing like the
decisions like how they differ between
the different directors this was so much
better
oh they're showing way more actions
she's like nah get out of here i was
like yo
the zack snyder cut actually shows her
being a superhero yeah right the other
one's just like
i watched like half of the first wonder
woman they didn't really sell wonder
woman as being like this powerful
character in my opinion oh she wouldn't
spice and stuff like that we don't see
her like be faster you don't see her be
stronger it's like throws a punch and
just a person gets blasted back but it's
like you don't actually get to see that
punch be you know super sonic yes it's
just a regular actor throwing a punch
and then just a guy on a wire it's cool
to actually see her
be fast and show the punches in the
moves at the speeds they would have to
be at to do that to people yeah
that part where she knocks the goon
towards them catches them and throws
them is that two wire gags it's either
wire gag or sometimes they'll use
nothing because right now that guy's
physics look really really gummy that
doesn't look like it's a real person
which is crazy to think that that's what
a stunt performer has to also do you
have to play pretend with something
that's supposed to have weight and be
able to catch it and then throw yeah and
sell that so that way they can then put
a double there a digital copy for it to
match your actions totally can we talk
about how it's so goofy that they
decided in the old cut just have a guy
come up and hit her in the back of the
head
yeah that'll help
it's like why it allows her to flip her
hair when writing a character there's a
philosophy you can apply which is the
moment a character makes a decision that
would not be a human decision to make is
the moment your character stops feeling
human you know these days most big
directors are good at not doing that for
their non-action scenes but when they
get to an action scene it's like they
get lazy on that in my opinion you need
to treat your action scenes with your
characters like you treat your dialogue
scenes with your characters they're both
important because it's so clearly a
throwing moment it's not a human
decision you don't ever do that it's not
logical and you're just like meh i love
this man
man will you come and direct project h
when it gets off the ground yeah will
you please yeah hit me up anytime i love
this man
on set we sit there and just cringe when
they go ahead and do stuff like we go no
no no don't do that it happens it
legitimately happens all the time
because you get a director who is so
good with developing these characters
that they're not strong with action you
should really consult with either your
action director your stunt coordinator
or your fight coordinator it's okay to
not have an answer but you should at
least go ahead and really logically
think about it zack snyder thank you
very much for taking that out because it
was completely right i'll keep it short
and sweet
please consider subscribing
two seconds
[Music]
i know i've watched most of jackie's
stuff i haven't seen armor of god this
is his version of like what his indiana
jones yeah indiana jones with jackie
chan signing me up
this is some spry monks right these
monks are about to get it
one of the bowls went straight in the
camera do you see that
[Applause]
jackie's always really good about his
guys knowing that they're gonna do a gag
to stay active in in the scene but not
distracting but he's active so he's not
just standing there you know what i mean
you always got to know what your next
thing is because you're shooting all the
stuff in sequence probably and this
thing you take 10 minutes to set it up
yeah knock it out and you're probably
not thinking about what's the next shot
yeah because you know you're so focused
on this moment but it's really important
with action especially stuff like this
to be like okay the next shot we're
gonna do in this sequence is me running
from frame right
so in this shot and i always make sure
i'm carrying that momentum out of this
shot and it just cuts perfectly jackie's
edits are some of the tightest yeah like
and you know he's the one in the editing
room with the editor going no yeah he
needs to be here so that this flows wow
that's one of those famous jackie wire
poles yep and adding the element of the
breakaway that make it just look even
more violent yeah it's ingenious that's
one of those things with one scene like
that doesn't necessarily cost more money
to do that's just good knowledge of your
sleight of hand and your craft
oh that taco's so nice there is a famous
ghee taco his face like this in a taco
yeah
vlad started or was it tony choosing
it
those are the things that take like
what a finisher yeah jackie was serving
hands to everybody something that's
always important and always prevalent in
every sort of jackie film is your
beginning and your ending you always
make sure that he opens big and he
finishes strong always everything in
between is filler but even his filler is
amazing you know what i mean but he
always knows no i need something big at
the end it's important because you know
that your average audience isn't going
to remember all of the fine intricate
choreography it's the moment yeah
this is the finale fight to the first
kenshin film the actor in this movie
they did a such a good job of covering
him but also giving him his highlights
kenshin's whole thing is he is a
defensive sort of swordsman he doesn't
want to kill anyone so a lot of times
he's on the ropes
oh this little bit watch
behind the back oh
i've been trying to put my finger on
what makes this sword fighting style
feel different from other movies i feel
like part of it's a little bit what
you're talking about with the blade bit
where it's the swings aren't this it's
the sword's in
like pulling the blade across and then
you know the impact happens yeah kenji
tanagaki is responsible for the actual
action in this they do a lot of
traditional japanese style but they also
elongate a lot of things
[Music]
i don't think this is padded because
those are like some like ancient actual
steps right there there's no way to
actually pad those i think the stunt
double had to pad up really really well
and they did a really good job of hiding
everything that they were wearing what's
important to know about this is the
whole setup this scene this entire fight
i would guess took them a few weeks yeah
because not only are we changing
locations we've got big stunts we've got
both actors in the action and it's also
environment dependent meaning weather
dependent we're out in the elements yeah
so this stuff takes time this is art
this is storytelling it's not dependent
on the budget throw that budget out the
window yes and no i mean i don't throw
it out entirely
you don't get that in a typical sort of
american setting a lot of times on tv
shows or films what we're given is a day
or half a day to do big big action
whenever they say you guys have a day
for the fight that includes the lead-up
to the fight and then there's been a
whole day until lunch time to get you to
finally throw the first punch this is
the first punch if any of you guys out
there are trying to do action scenes and
getting into filmmaking and you want to
do action or martial arts or whatever
when you get your fight scenes and
you're trying to figure out how do i
balance my time and my money and my
resources i would encourage you to go to
a skeleton crew go to a really small
crew and then take your time and film
the action scene and take all the time
you need right because at the end of the
day an action scene can just be your two
actors and a camera person you can if
you have to you could just be those
three people and you can go a long time
filming with just three people have just
a basic game plan but be open to
suggestions about how to better cover
your action because it's gonna make your
product that much better it's a
collaborative effort so trust your team
the people that you hire to do your job
you know trust in the coordinators trust
in the action directors and the actions
gonna come out amazing because you're
allowing them to do what they love to do
and what they're passionate about
[Music]
all right aaron usually i push for
people to leave a comment to you know
help recommend clips but what's some
stuff you would like to see i want to
see more fight scenes using environments
we know jackie can do that stuff but i
would love to see some of these other
genres using stuff yeah if you guys can
give us some recommendations
we'd really appreciate it thank you
all right if you've been watching this
channel for a while you probably know
that we love coffee around here it keeps
stuntmen alert it keeps vfx artists
awake and it just keeps the party going
day or night whenever you're drinking it
so any chance that i have to get more
coffee in the hands of more people is a
good day for me which is why i'm super
excited to tell you about today's
sponsor trade coffee now what trade does
is they offer some of the best roasts
from top roasters all over the world
directly to your home it's incredible
and one thing that they have just in
time for summer is a cold brew kit you
probably think cold brew is crazy to
make takes all this time but guess what
with trade's cold brew at home system
they take all that away and just leave
you with a convenient affordable and
tasty way to get cold brew right in your
cup think of trade's new cold brew kits
as a one-stop shop to make cold brew at
home it's an all-in-one system including
coffee and brew method that allows you
to make next level cold brew without any
hassle and at an affordable cost you
sign up at drinktrade.com to receive
freshly roasted cold brew coffee along
with easy to use cold brew brewing bags
you set your delivery schedule flavor
preferences grind and bag size before
you get started you then get that coffee
delivered to you and trades signature
red bags which are also compostable by
the way trade also offers free shipping
so don't worry about that trade is so
confident about this that they offer a
guaranteed you'll love it first bag
meaning that if you don't love it they
guarantee that you will they're gonna
send you a new bag for free now this
whole new cold brew kit that trade has
put together can give you a cold brew
cup for as little as one dollar per cup
are you spending one dollar a cup on
your coffee right now probably not
totally went down the wrong way
obviously you can see i've had a lot of
caffeine and coffee today so i'm up so
if you guys are interested in trying out
trade for yourself click the link in the
description below and the first 100
people to use the code corridor crew 50
will get 50
off their first order just wanted to let
you know and uh now back to stuntman
react
you guys need to go check out aaron and
gee's instagrams at gee extra silva and
at aaron tony we'll have links in the
description below they post some really
cool stuff some cool behind the scenes
footage examples of their work if you
like these clips are playing on the show
go check out their instagrams and keep
your eye out for a little project that
aaron's been working on called project h
nothing's online yet nothing but i got
to see a teaser of it what i'm jealous
hey you were late okay
don't pass this narrative on me
he rushed here on his bike he got here
safely and effectively didn't i did very
fast
thanks for watching everybody really
appreciate it hope to see you in the
next episode
peace